Good afternoon.
It's great to be back and it's great
to be back with my very good friend Dan
Doctoroff, uh, who as you
know, has written a book,
which I think is actually fantastic.
If you want to understand how the city
around you, it was built, read this book.
If you want to understand how hard it is,
read this book.
If you want to understand what it takes
to transform a city during your adult
lifetimes here, read this book, uh,
and we'll have copies at the end, uh,
in the back of Danville side,
a few and so forth.
I'll ask a few questions and
as usual, then we'll have
your questions as well. Uh,
before we actually talk about the book,
what are you doing in Toronto?
Because everybody heard anything
about what sidewalk labs is doing,
so you know that, so I was
deputy mayor for uh, uh,
six years and then I ran Bloomberg Lp.
Um,
and then when Mike Bloomberg decided that,
you know,
he wanted to get back involved
in the business side, I said,
I want to go do something on my own.
And so we teamed up together a Google now,
alphabet and me,
and we created sidewalk labs and sidewalk
labs is a bat just like Waymo and
others.
And our mission is fundamentally
to improve life in cities.
Um, and we're going about it
in a, I think incredible way.
I am so excited about this.
Um, we want to build, um,
a city are really a district of a city.
And so just a few weeks ago we announced
that we're partnering with Toronto.
Uh, I've not learned how to say Toronto
actually for those of you who are right,
there's no big t on the end.
Toronto. It's like Toronto.
Toronto. Yeah. And uh, um,
it is an amazing city for those of
you who haven't ever been there.
It's really close to here, like an
hour and 15 minutes away. But, um, we,
when we say we want to
build a district or a city,
we want to be able to show
how bringing together um,
great urban design and cutting edge
technology on an integrated basis across
kind of every urban system.
So how we get around sustainability,
the nature of buildings,
public space,
community and social
services driven by data.
How we can fundamentally bend the curve
on every aspect of quality of life.
Can we actually, and we believe
we can based on two years of work,
which Eric has helped to guide us on.
Um,
can we dramatically reduce the cost
of living in a city? We believe that.
Can we actually create the only
climate positive place on earth?
We think it can be done.
Can we actually achieve vision zero
where there are no accidents on streets?
We think it can be done.
Can we give time-starved parents
an hour or more back in their day?
We think all of that can be done. This
isn't easy. This is big. It's long,
it's complex. Uh, but that's
what we're all about. And uh,
we're really excited about it. The, uh,
everybody at Google and alphabet
has been so supportive. Uh,
but we have a chance, I think to really
make history. And so I'm happy to talk
more about it and questions. We support
what you're doing incredibly. Yeah,
it's been rough. The whole team
has boundaries talking about it.
So let's talk about New York.
Um,
your book largely begins with your
inauguration of Mike Bloomberg, the mayor,
and you sort of running
everything with him. Um,
and one of the first things you did is
you did an assessment of the city from
the standpoint of being
kind of in charge of it. Um,
and you had a number of very interesting
observations, housing shortage.
We're dealmaking take us through,
take us back to 2002,
right? Nine 11 is just happened. The
city is recovering from the horror,
horrific tragedy. Has It feel,
what'd you learn? What'd you see?
It was kind of terrifying. I'm on the, the
one hand,
on the other hand,
the title of my book greater than ever
comes from sort of the declaration that
then mayor Rudy Giuliani made
literally on nine 11 that New Yorkers,
we're not going to be intimidated
by the terrorist attack,
the tragedy, and instead we're going
to make the city greater than ever.
And that as a rallying cry actually
I think enabled a lot of what we were
subsequently able to do.
So on the one hand you came in and the
city was basically destroyed financially
it was a rack, um, physically
because of nine 11 you say that?
Oh yeah, totally. Nine, 11,
the number of jobs and people who fled
the city in the immediate aftermath of
nine 11 was really kind of frightening.
You know,
we lost that tens of thousands of
tourism jobs, literally overnight.
The financial services sector,
which was concentrated downtown,
many of the firms to camp almost
immediately to New Jersey. Um,
there were, there's a great
kind of article, I mean,
terrible article in a way in the New York
Times questioning whether New York and
its existing model of openness sort
of would actually be able to survive.
So that was the conditions
that we came into.
So you had a whole area of
the city that was destroyed.
Most of the rest of the world thought more
of New York was destroyed financially.
The budget was a disaster.
We were facing a $5 billion
budget deficits in our first year.
Literally that opened up overnight. Um,
and emotionally the city was on edge.
So the question is, what do you do
about it? And a, it's, Eric said the,
one of the first things that we did is
we stepped back and said, you know what,
let's think of New York with
a completely clean slate.
I mean in the sense that let's
look at it in an unvarnished way.
What are our strengths? What are
weaknesses, the way you would a business.
And so we literally brought in
consulting firms, they did a ton of work.
We looked at different businesses and
whether they ought to be in New York or
not. And um, and out of
that evolved a strategy,
um,
that we pursued pretty
relentlessly for the next 12 years.
And you know, I like to think that,
you know, while wasn't perfect, um,
overall we really got
the band was interesting.
One of the things that
you first discovered,
which you shouldn't be paying
off businesses by in the city.
And this is a time when
everyone's leaving, right?
So everyone's coming
to the city and saying,
I want $1 billion tax
abatement or what have you.
And in the book you actually tell the
stories of what actually happened and he's
very difficult discussions with people
who had been promised large windfalls.
Right. And you canceled them. We did.
And this was almost right away. Um,
we just believe based on that analysis
that people were either going to stay
here or not based on what
ever they needed in the,
ultimately the economics of being here.
So companies that really had sort
of a significant amount of kind of
intellectual capital that
we're powering the business,
they were going to stay because
they could find better people here.
We really believe that that companies
that were extremely cost conscious at the
end of the day over time,
and whether it was a division or a unit
of a company that was really dependent
upon sort of very tight margins,
we couldn't keep them here by,
we had almost no manufacturing
jobs left in the city.
And so we developed a strategy and this
one of the stories that you're referring
to as the New York Stock Exchange,
right? So New York Stock Exchange,
it's been down in Wall Street basically
since 1792 the Giuliani administration
with the state had negotiated a one point
$1 billion package to move them into a
new headquarters across the street.
Said 1.1 billion.
We don't have 1.1 billion in
this day and age. And by the way,
we think I should also point out that
the stock market's going to go completely
electronic. So what do they
need a whole new building for?
Even though we had actually
already purchased on their
behalf of building across
the street and we're paying
rent to other people,
we just decided to kill it. And of
course the stock has changed it and move.
And of course there's literally nobody
working on the trading floor anymore
other than like reporters from my old
company like Bloomberg because they need a
good stage, uh, to show what's actually
happening in financial markets.
We did the same thing by the way,
baseball stadiums,
both the Yankees and the mats had deals
with the Juliet Giuliani Administration
for new stadiums that would have required
the city to put up most of the money.
We killed them on day one.
One of the,
one of the interesting stories that
you talk about is when you started,
you realized that there was this acute
housing shortage and then no one was
addressing the affordable
housing shortage. Uh,
and it seems like there's
plenty of housing in the
city. It's just too expensive.
So you're saying there wasn't enough
or you were saying there wasn't enough
housing in general?
Are there wasn't a housing
have afforded? We said was we
believed in the future of New York.
We came in with an extremely sort of,
despite the conditions,
extremely optimistic view that um,
and that the goal of a city
is actually to grow, um,
that, you know, I just grow or die.
It's grow or die and that we needed,
would need over time to accommodate
the growth that we hope to generate.
And that growth would require Watsa
housing and that would require housing at
every price point for all income levels.
And so at a time when we
didn't have any money,
when no one was calling for
an affordable housing plan,
um, when in Mike's campaign,
either he nor his opponent, um,
actually had any plans for
affordable housing. Um,
literally within months
after him becoming mayor,
we announced what was to
become the largest municipal
affordable housing program
of all time. Now the reality is
that even at the end of the day,
it wasn't enough. The city actually
grew faster than we thought.
You know, when we came into office are
about 8 million people in New York,
there's now about 8.6
million people in New York.
So we've added over the
last 15 years in this city,
a city in effect the size of
Boston or bigger than Atlanta,
I think, or Miami. And we tried
to produce enough housing.
I don't think we actually have.
Um,
and that it was probably one of my,
Oh, in, in the politics
and the politics, let's,
let's say that your mantra directly
or indirectly is grow or die, right?
That cities need investment. And
a, I see as I walk around the city,
nothing but construction,
which of course inconvenience is the
traffic but produces many high paying,
high quality jobs.
I ever had any traffic in the Bloomberg
administration ever had any traffic. So,
so who fights you when you
have a growth or die mindset?
Who is your opponent?
Uh, a lot of people. Um, the, the,
the big question is how do you
accommodate the growth, right?
How do you physically,
so in order to accommodate that growth,
we literally looked across
the entire city and said,
we've got to create more,
um,
land so people can build more housing.
Well as other stuff.
And in order to do that, you have to
go through a process called zoning.
And that is a extremely public process.
And we did over 12 years,
140 separate rezonings. So, you know,
like the area around the high line,
which was part of one of the rezonings
West Chelsea, right? We're right here.
So that was west of ninth avenue was
zoned complete or the guest west of 10th
was on completely for manufacturing.
We wanted it to have housing there.
We also saved the high
line at the same time.
So everybody was opposed to
it at the very beginning. Uh,
because like they didn't want
housing across the street. I mean,
what are the great things you'll learn
in government is no matter what your
proposed,
no matter how good it is,
there's going to be people that
are going to hate it. I mean,
literally hate it and they're,
they've got a valid, um,
a way to express it. Uh,
and you have to overcome it.
So it,
most likely it's going to be the local
residents who are affected by whatever it
is you want to do.
Because know we got good at listening
to the residents and reflecting their
comments and doing which
lands and then mostly doing,
so if we go back to two, should
a Moses, Robert Moses, right?
That was another growth,
her die strategy,
which ended in sort of a
horrific outcome for him. Right?
He should have built
all the energy changes.
And then when he finally
proposed this interchange,
the basically a highway across Manhattan
and having sort of destroyed the south
Bronx, um, and he's, you know, a few
years earlier that was sort of the,
and there was this huge political
upwelling against him. Um,
how did you figure out a way
to avoid the Robert Moses fee?
We,
a couple of things.
One is we actually listened to
communities that was important,
but I think the more important
thing is we basically went,
were know as where, as few people as
possible. Actually we're so, you know,
over the course of these 12, I think
even in the six years that I was there,
we had completely changed the way we
thought about the city from a land use
perspective. We rezoned, you know,
a huge percentage of the city creating
room for 120 million square feet,
huge and commercial areas,
residential areas. Uh,
we created I think two,
3000 acres of parks.
Um,
we built three stadiums or arenas.
Um, we, you know, we talked a lot
about the affordable housing itself.
We built a subway. Um, and
literally out of all of that,
I think we displaced, you
know, 400 people, right?
We didn't.
So the secret,
the secret was finding spaces where
you could get a small percentage of
population who are sort of annoyed and
work with them and ultimately build
something that benefited.
That's exactly right.
And,
and where that tended to be is in
the old industrial areas of the city.
People don't realize it today,
but you know, after World War Two,
and even before World War II,
New York was like a great
manufacturing center.
There was a million manufacturing
jobs in New York after World War II.
By the time we came into
office there were 140,000 left.
But because people retain this sort
of romantic notion that manufacturing,
big manufacturing,
lots of jobs are going to come back.
The city had never done anything with
all of the buildings and the land that
used to be industrial but
was now essentially vacant.
And most of that was along the waterfront
in Brooklyn and Queens on the west
side of Manhattan and the area around
downtown Brooklyn in the South Bronx.
And we said no more nostalgia.
Um,
what we're going to do is make that
land available for residential,
commercial sparks every,
we did all these plans for all these
neighborhoods and look at long island city
for so long.
I say,
so I don't know how many of you
guys live in either Williamsburg,
Greenpoint or long island city
for example. So a few here.
Everyone else probably lives
somewhere in Brooklyn, but the uh, um,
those areas,
there was nothing there at all.
So you look around sorta across the
river from Manhattan and look at what's
happening over there. None of it
existed. So downtown Brooklyn,
by the way,
exactly the same thing,
the, um, one of the things that
happens throughout your book,
you just spent an awful lot of
time talking about the Olympics.
Now had you asked me in 2002,
if you are a crazy idea of getting the
Olympics to New York City was a good idea.
I would have said no,
but in your book you become more and
more convinced of your rightness.
So why don't you defend yourself now.
But it's clear that the Olympics and more
seriously really helped you understand
what it would take to transform
the city. Yeah. Right.
That the mechanism of planning
for the Olympics, right.
Forcing you to think
through every aspect of it,
then con created the conditions
that would create the outcome. You,
yeah. Not So. So give you a
little bit of background on that.
So I had the crazy idea that New York
actually ought to host the Olympics.
And I had it,
you know,
back in 1994 when somebody asks me to go
to the World Cup semifinal game out at
giants stadium and the metal lands
happened to be Italy versus Bulgaria,
two teams. I could not have cared
less about an s in a sport I hated.
Um,
and,
and a friend dragged me out on a hundred
degree day in July to this brutally
Kinda hot and a game.
And we took the bus,
it took forever.
And I'm walking into the stadium
cursing and I walk in and it's the most
exciting event that I have ever seen.
And I sat there thinking to myself,
you know,
the thing that's so amazing about New
York is you could play that game in a
stadium in New York with virtually
any two countries in the world.
And the feeling would be exactly the same.
And then as I was standing there,
you literally couldn't sit down the
whole time I thought to myself, well,
why has New York,
the most international city in the world,
I've subsequently been corrected? And
it's actually Toronto, believe it or not,
but why the mayor of Toronto
reinforces that all the time.
Why his New York,
the thought to be most international
city in the world never hosted the most
international event,
the Olympics.
So I left the stadium that day with this
vague notion that New York auto host
the Olympics.
And over the next two years I
researched it just on my own,
did all sorts of research
about what it takes to win.
Is it a good thing or bad thing?
And I finally had an insight.
And ironically the insight
came to me from Toronto,
which had bid for the 1996 Olympics.
We originally were focused on 2008 where
what they had done with their plan had
placed all of the venues and then plans
for the neighborhoods around them,
um,
on the w on your utilized waterfront.
And the key point was at the Olympics
could be a catalyst to getting things done
that the city had wanted to do but could
never generate the political will or
the financial wherewithal to get done.
And what I finally concluded was you
could see the same thing just for bidding
for the Olympics.
And so what I did was I assembled a team,
we built a plan, um, for the city,
the physical future of the city where we
placed sort of then use proposed venues
in the areas that we thought
needed the most help,
had plans for the areas around them
and figure that just by the process of
bidding for the Olympics and the
deadlines that the bidding process impose,
it would create the
catalyst to get things done.
And that's actually exactly what happened,
but kind of by a fluke.
So what happened was we developed this
plan. This is before I was deputy mayor.
The plan,
actually I've schlepped it to round to
all sorts of business people because I
needed money for the bid.
One of the people that I actually met
in that process was a guy named Mike
Bloomberg, um, who gave me some
money and went onto our board.
Um,
actually didn't care at all about it,
but he adopted a bunch of the ideas
when later on he ran for mayor.
And then when in a complete shock,
he actually won only because of nine 11.
He asked me to join him in city hall and
do the things that I'd wanted to do as
part of the Olympic bid and get them
all approved before the Olympic bid
decision three years later.
And so that's exactly what we did.
So Hudson yards, for example, guys know
about Hudson yards. That was a plan.
That was originally Olympic plan.
The Greenpoint,
Williamsburg waterfront was an old part
of the Olympic plan, Long Island city,
downtown Brooklyn.
Um,
some of the improvements in flushing and
Coney island and Harlem and the South
Bronx, all of those were part of those
original plans. So you know, we lost,
you know, we didn't have
the Olympics here. Um,
but at the end of the day,
you know, we kind of won.
But it's interesting that losing
the Olympics but having built the
infrastructure that the Olympics was
supposed to create might be the best
economic outcome for an Olympic city.
Right. We got to all the, see all,
we got all the benefits from your work
now we would have had another seven years
of deadlines to get other stuff done.
Well let's talk and so,
and by the way,
just so you know,
it would have been a great
celebration of what New York is,
which is sort of my original. There
are more Olympics in the future. Nah,
I think we've used up all the land.
There's almost no place to go.
I that's get it off. That's at your
predecessor said. Let's talk about, uh,
people will find a way. There is
one place, but I got my eye there,
there, there, there are
a couple of areas in,
in the book you talk about this where
you ultimately lost politically or for
whatever reason. Let's, let's
talk about a few of those.
You wanted to be last week.
Yes.
I think it's important because it's
illustrative of how hard this stuff is,
which is always for the average citizen.
The average is like why is this so hard?
The answer is it's really hard.
So let's use the stadium as an example.
You worked really hard to get a stadium.
Why do we not have a stadium there?
Tell it,
take us through the stadium.
So, um, so those are the guys
who weren't here at the time.
Um,
part of the Hudson yards plan,
only one piece of it was to build a
Reese called it the New York sports and
convention center, which
was going to be, uh,
an an adjunct to the convention center,
but would also serve as the
home for the New York jets.
It's going to be an amazing facility
and we worked really hard to make it
happen. Uh, and the reason
ultimately didn't happen.
It was defeated in Albany,
the state capitol. Um,
by, uh, really one guy,
the one guy's guy named
Sheldon silver, who's the speaker of
the assembly recently heard his name.
We have, because, uh, he
was convicted of corruption.
Um,
and uh,
that conviction unfortunately was
overturned on a legal technicality.
So we are looking
forward,
I say this very publicly to his retrial,
but said, so you have an opinion
about Shelton, Mr Mr. Seller?
I absolutely do.
But in any event,
um, you know, he thought, uh,
there were several reasons that I think
he rejected it because it all came down
to one guy.
One was was that he had to cozy
relationship with Madison Square Garden,
which opposed having a competing
facility. Um, secondly,
he thought our plans for the west side
of Manhattan would compete with the plans
to redevelop lower Manhattan,
which we always said what's crazy New
York and handle two big developments at
the same time. But his district
was in lower Manhattan. Third, um,
he was having an affair
with the lobbyist, uh, four,
four K for Cablevision or so it
is reputed on good authority.
Um,
and uh,
fourth his members of his, um, his, uh,
democratic caucus who are from the west
side who were very supportive of him
when there was an attempted coup of
him like a couple of years before. Um,
we're very much opposed to the steam
because they hate everything that, uh,
and to this day that is
proposed to be done, uh,
in their district.
And then I will say in the spirit
of complete candor was Hubris on,
um, my, my side. Um,
we always knew he was
going to be a problem.
We tried to do an end run around
the legislature that end run failed.
And I think he was basically telling us
that he was the real power and swatted
us really me down.
So it's a combination of all of those.
Life is tough,
but let's use another example.
Governor Christie canceled this tunnel,
which in my reading was critically
needed. Yup. How does this happen?
Well, he did some other things too.
Here's how these things happen.
It's people,
politicians generally have no courage.
Okay. And generally speaking, there are,
there are clearly exceptions,
one of whom I was incredibly
proud to serve and there
are, there are many others.
So what for him, you know, he had
like a great first year as governor,
um,
and he was really popular and he started
having what all popular politicians do,
uh,
dreams and becoming the president.
He understood that in order to
be a viable Republican candidate,
um,
he needed to show sort of real sort
of fiscal toughness and conservatism.
So he ended up this plan to build a new
tunnel between New Jersey and New York
City.
He claimed that he had no
confidence that the cost of it,
you know, would come
in where they said, um,
which itself was probably not totally
unfair, but he just killed it.
And as the single dumbest thing that
you could ever do for New Jersey,
New Jersey at the end of
the day exists because,
because two,
please continue. By the way, I
just in my, in my defense here,
I wasn't in my friend's living,
I was born in Newark. So, uh, go ahead.
What am I saying that my parents made
the wise decision to move to Detroit. So,
uh,
so in any of it,
no,
I didn't mean New Jersey benefits by
virtue of its proximity to New York City.
The more people who can get in and
out of New York from New Jersey,
it's a corollary of my
virtuous cycle of growth,
grow or die for New Jersey to grow
more people have to keep coming
in and out. In New York if you want to
increase the aggregate growth rate of the
metropolitan region, you have to increase
its connectivity, right? In all forms.
Nope.
By the way,
you probably read like these
tunnels between New York
and New Jersey are ancient
and there's pose a huge risk and one of
them is a hundred years old and it has
to be shut down.
It's going to collapse now.
We're going to spend many times
more money. It'll take a lot.
We're spending really risking.
So speaking of don't live in New Jersey
seeking of interconnectivity,
um, the city has,
so, so the good news is there's more
housing, there's more economic activities,
more buildings,
more travel and its economic growth.
And it is really the center of economic
growth for America today as a whole.
And congratulations.
And by the way,
during the Bloomberg era,
job growth in the city was more than
double the national growth rate.
Uh, and more, most importantly
New York, cause it's a very,
it's a cyclical city generally because
we're so dependent on financial services
tends to go into recession faster and
come out slower because the recovery of
the financial system and financial
services firms tends to be slower in this,
um,
fit in the financial crisis.
The reverse happened because we actually
were successful very deliberately in
diversifying the economy. So that
included, you know, life sciences,
higher education where we
made lots of investments or
yeah,
you actually identify what are the things
you did in your initial plan as you
identified sectors of life sciences,
being in a film and television producer
in Rockefeller University and those
kinds of things. But, but
this is a lead up to my,
that the good news is you built
this incredibly strong city.
The bad news is taxes are incredibly high.
They're still an
affordability housing problem.
And the transportation is very difficult.
I'm going to use the word sucks now and,
and there was a summer of
hell, right this, this pens to,
and this is one problem after the other.
And that's something that the
private sector cannot fix, right?
It requires sustained coordination
across all three states and the city.
Is it just going to get worse?
So the answer
is hopefully not. Um, and I should,
let's talk, we talked a little bit
about affordability where it said,
I think the city just grew faster.
Um,
then for then we were able
to produce housing. Um,
talk about kind of transportation system.
I will say that from
the mass transit system,
um, it's not the city's fault. Um,
and the reason is the mass transit
systems controlled by the state.
And you know,
we talked about,
we had one other big failure and that
failure was back in 2007 as part of what
we called plan YC,
which was New York sustainability plan,
which is our plan for the
physical future of the city.
Looking out over 25 years.
Um,
we proposed a completely different
approach to mass transit,
a core piece of which was
going to be congestion pricing.
For those of you who've been
in London or maybe Singapore,
you know that when you
enter a zone, um, the,
uh, you pay a in a car, I'm not taxis,
but private vehicles,
you actually pay a fee.
We proposed and $8 fee below 86th street
in Manhattan and it was ultimately
going to generate like $1 billion
a year. And we promised, um,
that all of that would be given to
the MTA, which we don't even control,
which is run by the state, run
by the state, could be bonded,
combined with an additional
annual contribution in the
city would make and the
state would make,
um,
could fund $50 billion in mass transit
improvements and all of it would have
been guaranteed. And we even specify
what lines we're going to get added,
what subway stations we're
going to get improved. You know,
how much greater frequency bus
rapid transit, like a whole plan.
But the core of it was congestion pricing.
And by the way,
just in terms of statistics,
this gives you a sense for how politics
actually works among in the districts of
the legislators because this had to get
approved in Albany who we're going to be
most affected by congestion pricing.
The ones typically like
on the outer boroughs, um,
on the other side of the river.
Um,
literally like 5% of constituents
drove into Manhattan and 95% would have
benefited from these mass
transit improvements. But again,
it was defeated by the
same guy up in Albany. Um,
and will you have an opinion?
Well,
I have an opinion about now what is
interesting as result of the summer of how
and all the underfunding
of the transit system,
the idea of congestion pricing are
totally the bridges coming back.
So the good news, I guess they
still have to solve this problem.
Let me ask you one final quick question.
Good news is we'll eventually
be proven to be correct. Okay.
The bad news is it'll probably
happen 15 years later, but um, yeah.
Usually when you push problems off,
they physically are you sure
you're better off fixing them.
Now I have one final question and I'd
like to ask the audience for your comments
or questions. Um, what's the weirdest or
funniest thing Donald Trump did with you?
Uh, I'll tell you two quick
stories that I think, um,
illustrate my general rule
that people just don't change.
And everything we're saying
was ultimately predictable.
And I will point out that I actually had
a pretty good relationship with them.
But you know what? Columbus circle. Um,
so the city actually,
I inherited a piece of property,
um,
that we decide we're going to sell
off this in 2002 when we had no money.
And in the previous administration,
they'd gone through a process and they'd
selected Trump who is going to build a
luxury boutique gold plated hotel.
And so we decided we ought to see what
else is out there. So we went out,
we did an RFP and there were
really two bitters for it. One was,
um, Trump who wanted to build
the same gold plated hotel.
I actually don't remember for
sure that it was gold play,
but you can imagine it would have been.
And um,
and the other was a small museum that
wanted to move to a more prominent
location on Columbus Circle.
And this,
this building had been a museum.
So anyway,
so we get the bids and Trump
offers all cash, a lot more money.
Um, and uh, we'll pay today
or that, you know, right away.
And the museum, which had no
money offered to pay less money,
would pay when they could raise
it, um, if the, if they could.
So needless to say,
we chose the museum.
So now you can imagine the call
with Trump to inform him that,
um, we had selected this pathetic
little museum, which by the way,
if you haven't been to the Museum
of art and design is a great museum.
So you can imagine sort of how
that call went and you know,
but this is the more interesting story.
I did not hear a word from him for like
another 15 months until the day after
the apprentice debuted on NBC.
And I get a call the next
day from him out of the blue.
And the entire point of the call was
for him to tell me the ratings of the
apprentice.
I literally had not heard from the guy
for 15 months and I could not have been
number like 1000 on his list,
but was more amazing.
Was he called me every week like clockwork
for the next three weeks to tell me
the rate. Are you sure he didn't confuse
you with a different, I don't think so.
So here's the final thing,
which we'll again,
we'll tell you everything you need
to know. So on the day I die, I,
we announced that I was leaving
city hall to go to Bloomberg.
I sent out a note to like a
thousand people, you know,
who I'd worked with saying what a great
experience and an honor, blah, blah, blah.
It was, and yeah,
attached the press release of all
the great things that we did. Um,
and like hundreds of people wrote back
these incredibly nice notes. I mean,
it was, it was really moving.
So I get one back from, from,
uh, from Trump. And, uh,
what he had done was he had a scammed
printed out and scanned my email,
um, after and then circled
on it. No, say wrote,
great job, exclamation point,
exclamation, some big felt tip pen.
And then down below there was a
little typo in my email to him.
That was actually two periods at the
end of a sentence. He circled it.
This is the guy who
spells taps with two P's.
He circled it and put an exclamation point
on.
How do you explain that
since from our audience?
My question is, how can the city, uh,
arrest control from Albany in order
to do some of the things that you've
described? Well, one
option would be to succeed.
I was known to privately advocate that
from time to time the answer is actually
a more creeping takeover.
Um,
so I talk a little bit in the book about
a governor's island and Brooklyn Bridge
Park. You guys all been to governor's
island, Brooklyn Bridge Park. So, um,
we actually,
um,
bought both governors island and the
land underlying governor's island and
Brooklyn Bridge Park in
partnership with the state.
Um,
early on,
literally in the first six months to
a of the Bloomberg administration and
managing it with the state.
Both of them was awful.
Um, you know, they wouldn't share
information, they are incredibly slow,
bureaucratic, whatever, and
it was really frustrating.
So,
uh,
eventually I got so frustrated that I
brought a team together and we developed a
plan, which we called Project Repo, uh,
to buy the state out of its interests
in governor's island and Brooklyn Bridge
Park. And at first week we
close to having a deal. Um,
when our governor Pataki was
governor then Eliot Spitzer name,
many of you may remember who was governor
for about 15 months until he had a sex
scandal. Um, he didn't want
anything to do with it.
He was so insistent on state control
over literally as much as possible.
And so we waited and this happened after
I left for his successor to come when
the city's position, after the financial
crisis was stronger than the states.
And my successor actually agreed to
buy their out their interests and no
intimate too to a large degree,
that incredible public spaces that,
um,
Brooklyn Bridge Park and governor's
island are as a result of that decision to
buy them out.
So the reality is beyond like
weird situations like that,
the truth is we just have
to do our best job. In fact,
I would say one of my great regrets,
I joke a lot about the state is that I
should have been up in Albany a lot more,
um, being nice to those guys. Um, instead,
the path I chose was to ignore
them as much as possible.
And for the most part that worked fine.
The couple of times I talked about
didn't work so well. Yeah. All right,
next question. Where do you live?
Upper west side. Upper West.
We're neighbors. Yes. Originally
from the suburbs of Detroit.
And understand you grew up there as well.
Which one? Uh, from Huntington Woods.
My brother lives in Huntington against.
What can Detroit learn from New York City?
That's a great question.
Um, and uh, uh,
I actually gave a speech
about this every year.
Detroit has like this homecoming
event for people who fled Detroit,
you know, and, and you know,
Bidwell somewhere else and they want
to get them encouraged. By the way,
I should say, I think Detroit is
actually on the upswing, but I,
I did give this speech and I actually,
um,
analogize Detroit, not to New
York City, but instead to Harlem,
which has begun to see a real renaissance.
And I,
I gave like four pieces of advice.
The first is at the end of the day,
where you really make progress is not on
the stadiums or even the shiny downtown,
which is fine.
It's in the neighborhoods.
And so you really got to focus on the
little stuff of building neighborhoods,
making them safer,
improving education,
clearing out the vacant lots,
all of which, by the way,
I think the current
mayor who's really good,
it focused on second is you can't
be impatient. You know, when,
when I was born, I'm older
than you. Um, in 1958,
Detroit had 1.8 5 million people.
Today the population is maybe 650,000,
so it took 60 years to get into this
mess and it's going to take several
generations. And so what you
have to actually be his patient.
The third piece of advice
is you gotta be diverse.
Um, you know, Detroit,
the population is essentially shrunk so
much that a lot of the people left are
the ones who really couldn't
leave. And so, you know,
the percentage that have any sort of
college education is extremely low.
Um,
and what you need to do is reflate the
city and the way you reflate the cities
by being more diverse. And
some of that is, you know,
people being attracted back
to the city from the suburbs.
I think a big part of it is
really encouraging immigration.
Um, but again, you grow or you die.
Detroit is the exact opposite of
what we hope to do here in New York.
And I'd say, you know, the last
part is Troy can't do it alone.
It's gotten relatively meager help from
the federal government to go through.
It's bail out. It went through
bankruptcy to go through. It's valid.
It did get help from the state.
Um,
and there's complicated political
issues between the city and the state.
Harlem as an example, had New
York City, we invested, you know,
I'm guessing over time,
billions of dollars in housing in Harlem,
incredibly trends and, and it is, um,
it's really transformed. And so a lot
of that wasn't affordable housing.
So it's those four things. Let's go
ahead. Yes, sir. Where do you live?
I actually grew up in the West village.
My first job for five years actually
worked for community board to posting
zoning signs. Uh, so very
familiar with that. Uh,
and I currently live in Brooklyn Heights.
Um,
I guess so my question having grown up
in the city and having seen so much of
the transformation during
my lifetime, um, you know,
neighborhood that I grew up in is now
very different from the one that used to
be and is now starting to contemplate
home buying myself. Let me ask you,
in a great tradition of New York,
you know, conversation, where would,
where would you be excited about
as a value buy in the city?
Ah,
and why?
Because I also know you play
three dimensional chess. Really?
Why as opposed to where
you would want us to move.
Okay.
We're giving
you advice. Um, and I will concede,
I'm slightly out of date on this and you,
what you were really looking for is
value place where I think assuming the
continued growth occurs,
you'll see the fastest growth or
probably be in the South Bronx. Um,
and there's a reason for that one,
it's really close to Manhattan,
midtown Manhattan or Manhattan. If find
the right place, it's on the subway.
There's some interesting building stock
there. You're starting to see it happen.
It's gotten dramatically safer.
That would be certainly one area.
Uh,
you know,
it's Kinda late now for places in northern
Manhattan like Washington heights and
that area there. But I think
that's a great neighborhood. Yeah.
You can just take the subway map,
always look at the,
take a subway map and look
at the relative rents, right.
And then decide where you are and then
make a judgment of how they'll appreciate.
Yeah. The closer you are
to Manhattan, I think,
um, uh, from a mass trans,
that's where the greatest value.
So look at the relative value
relative to the distance.
And that's where you'll generally find
pretty much any place in New York now
though is dramatically more
livable than it was 15 years ago.
One of your, one of Mike's priorities was
in fact the Bronx in general. We have,
you know, we had this whole five
borough strategies. So, um, you know,
and what I'm really proud ist of is said,
the areas that we invested the most in
have seen the most dramatic increases in
job creation and business
formation, um, as well.
So, um, you know, look,
I also find, you know,
big parts of Queens to be very compelling.
It depends on how easy it is to get
into get into Manhattan. And by the way,
I'm not saying that you have to have
access to Manhattan, the heat. He's,
he was federal property values,
property value. Yeah. We,
this is the financial industry,
a lot of that. Yes sir.
Where do you sunset parks and other one.
Hey, I'm Steve. I live
in Williamsburg. Yeah.
I was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about the reality of construction
costs in New York. Um, and I,
I mean that because you talked about
revenue sources that don't exist.
You talked about Christie killing
the tunnel project because of sort of
political considerations,
but our costs,
there seems to be a persistent gap
between the estimation and the reality.
It's probably not the
estimation in the reality.
It's just that costs here
are way too high. And um,
and if you compare like building us,
typically a s like a high rise building
in New Jersey versus New York City,
um, it's like 35% difference, 35%,
and at the same labor force, same basic
labor of wines at 35% more expensive.
The biggest issue is it's actually
not the, this different labor rules.
And so the Labor in New York City are
infinite for union work are infinitely
more generous than they are in New Jersey.
And that's just like years of contractors,
you know,
who negotiate with the unions
basically giving away a lot more.
Um, and um, big part of that,
it's not so much the wage is per se,
it is the feather bedding.
It is the work rules that make
it just a lot more expensive.
Um, so the question is
what do you do about that?
And the presumably with that 35% applies
to affordable housing as well. Well,
it's, this is the
interesting question. Um,
it does in many cases because the
city's rules require when it's spent,
when it is using its money to
pay for something in some form,
it tends to require La
Union labor be used.
And that's kind of a political thing.
What's happening though is that,
um,
nonunion labor is
becoming much more common.
The percentage of buildings that are
built with UDN labour in the city is
actually coming down.
So the market is kind of working,
but it's not really an efficient market
because there are all these rules that
basically government imposes.
As a side question,
do you have an opinion about the 57
street corridor and all the huge apartment
complexes that are unsold and
occupying my visual space?
You know, I look, I think, um, uh,
one in particular is hideously ugly.
So that's a problem happened after
I was there. Just to be clear. Um,
you know, look, I have a,
there's a, there's a couple
of things wrapped up in that.
One is are the buildings too tall?
And you know,
I have two minds of that.
One is they're kind of not in
context and for Central Park.
And the view from central park.
On the other hand, you know,
I do believe that New York is an
aspirational city and should be reaching
basically for the sky. Um, you know,
ever hire.
Um,
the second part is whether I actually
care that there's a bunch of billionaires
buying, um, apartments
there and not living there.
And the truth and matter is I actually
don't care so much because that was never
going to be a place where there's
going to be like affordable housing or
anything.
And the more economic activity that we
can generate here that helps [inaudible]
construction workers or other people,
that's a good thing.
Eventually what I do regret is there
were tax abatements for some of those
buildings that probably
shouldn't have been there,
but eventually they'll start paying taxes.
So I don't really see it like soaking
up the man because you've got this
rarefied group of people who are going
to be paying lots of money creating
economic activity and it wouldn't
affect anything else. Where do you live?
All right. I live in the West village and
I'm originally from Oakland, California.
Um,
so I was working at Google in mountain
view for five years and then I moved out
here two and a half years ago. I have
an affordable housing question. Uh,
so in New York I've seen that there seems
to be much greater affordable housing
stock out here versus where
I come from in the bay area.
I was wondering if you were
advising policy makers in
the San Francisco Bay area,
what best practices from New York and
affordable housing would you reckon?
Great. It's a great,
it's a great question.
So New York and the bay area really
different for several reasons,
but the most important of which
is, you know, New York, um,
city,
um,
is one city and we can think very
comprehensively over a large area.
Um, now it's not the region. Um,
but New York City is a big entity and
so we sort of saw the whole city as a
canvas and could target.
The problem I think in the bay area is
the biggest one is one of governance,
right? So you've got all these
different towns and cities,
all of which have their own particular
view about how little development and
usually it is little development
that they actually want.
Um, and um, as a result,
you can't be comprehensive in the
way that you think about it and you,
um,
delegate enormous power over the capacity
to grow and create that supply to
individual governmental units.
And that is sort of the biggest problems.
So I'd say the number one thing that they
could do there is actually figure out
a way it'll never happen.
But regional planning, okay.
This other absent that is,
you know,
each one of those jurisdictions
is Gunna have to become much more,
um, friendly to growing supply. Uh,
but they, you know, the problem is,
is that like the transportation
systems, you know, just keep,
can't keep up. There's no reached
real great planning there either.
And so you can't accommodate the demand.
And so the bay area feels on every
level like a pressure cooker.
Um, and you know, until you
solve the governance issue,
until you actually are able to think
regionally about the things that
accommodate demand,
um,
it's not going to change and it's probably
only gonna get worse until quality of
life declined so much that people aren't
going to want to be there anymore.
Now, you know, some places
are more enlightened. I mean,
look at San Jose for example in
Google's plans for San Jose. You know,
hopefully that will be a little bit of a
release valve for the area. Same thing,
you know, in Sunnyvale and stuff.
But it's, it's a real problem.
Um, this issue is a huge issue for
our employees in the bay area is yes,
you will know we've run out of time,
but we have three people
who have been standing.
So maybe we could have each of you say
where you are from and ask your question
then you can,
yeah, I'll do it. I'll do it.
Creative answers. Go ahead. Yeah. Where
do you live and what's your question?
I live in upper east side and
I grew up in Elmhurst, queens,
dance with the CEO again earlier.
Talk about governance.
And so like if I look at China,
so they have the Beijing
autonomous kind of governance,
the same who Shanghai and the US.
We kind of have that with Washington DC,
you know, in terms of really
innovating in the cities.
Now what if we could push for the u s
recognize certain cities like New York as
its own special economic unit.
That way it could be freed from
upstate New York to actually innovate.
The same is true by the way in Germany.
There are a number of federal states
that are essentially cities. Look,
I think it could be great.
I mean the city also gives a lot more
money to the state than it actually gives
back.
But the one thing that you generally
recognize about governments is they very
rarely, um, devolve power, um,
unless they're desperate. So, you know,
it's, it's great thing to think about,
but better happened. You've
been waiting. Sorry sir.
Uh,
where do you live and what's your
Brooklyn Heights?
I begrudgingly moved to Jersey City
because it was more affordable. Um,
my question is this,
there is a disproportionate amount of
the population concentrated in cities.
Do you think that trend will continue
or will things like autonomous cars,
teleworking or anything of that sort of
caused the influx to reverse basically,
where do you think populations there'll
be concentrated more moving forward?
Um,
well you've already actually starting to
see a little bit of a movement back to
particularly around high
cost urban centers, um,
back to the suburbs or
even excerpts. Uh, so I,
I don't think it's going to be through
this dramatic rush where everyone,
like in America is going
to move into the cities.
I think people want choice and it's
good that they actually have choice.
I think the question that you asked
about things like autonomous cars and
whether that's going to encourage,
um,
city dwelling or it's going to encourage
longer commutes a will to some extent
be a function of the way in which we
incentivize the use of those vehicles.
You know,
are we going to try and actually
discourage having too many cars on the,
are we going to, you know, we
don't know. And so, uh, I don't,
I think it's hard to tell and if you
read all the literature about it, it's,
it's really kinda up in the air.
I'm a believer in cities because I do
believe that for a very high percentage of
people,
they have a real desire for contact and
community that has to be face to face.
Not Everybody views that other people
view having a lot more green space.
I also think that when we
do have autonomous vehicles,
we're going to be able to carve back a
lot more space for open space and make
our cities if we handle
it well, um, more livable.
So I'm a total optimist about cities,
but I don't think they're the only answer.
That's how our final question,
where do you live?
Where's she live?
On the upper west side and I'm actually
also from the suburbs of Detroit.
Where are you from? Oh, that's
further out, right? It's still, yeah.
Um,
my question is that like,
regarding like gentrification,
there's concerns that,
you know,
the people who already lived there are
getting pushed out or that they feel that
they're not really in the community
anymore. Uh, how do you find, uh,
you know, a balance when you're making
these developments that, you know, you're,
you're sparing growth,
but you're also not like excluding
yeah. You don't look,
I actually think, um,
while gentrification or
affordability or related,
they're not completely overlapping.
I generally believe that
gentrification is a good thing.
Um,
and I believe gentrification can
occur with out unduly compromising
affordability.
I believe that for a number of reasons.
One is a very high percentage
of units in this city,
literally like a million,
have some form of rent control on them.
Um,
and that acts as a real,
um,
a buffer against rising prices.
I think though,
the real answer at the end of the day
is to continue to build more housing.
Um, but you know, when you
talk about gentrification, um,
it brings real benefits to that.
People don't talk about the people
who've been there for a long time,
who own their homes or apartments.
They're worth a lot more.
There are many better services.
I think the most important
thing is economic opportunity
in terms of jobs being
created. Um, tend to, um, um,
be greatest in areas that are gentrifying,
which creates opportunity for people.
Um, you know, as,
as I mentioned before in the areas that
we focused on with affordable housing
now in central Brooklyn,
like Bedford Stuyvesant
in the South Bronx, yeah,
in central Harlem where we invested a
huge amount of money to hopefully make
housing markets work,
but most of it was affordable.
We saw a huge increases in job growth
and business production with meaningful
declines in unemployment rates and
there really isn't a ton of evidence to
indicate that people were actually
forced out of their homes. Instead,
what we do is we just created more.
So if you judge the city
I the starting point,
January,
2002 or roughly nine 11,
I think you can see that Dan's
contribution was extraordinary.
His office today is in one
of the buildings that he
helped design and promote.
Right.
And you are a genuine sort of a
Patriot and lover of our city,
so thank you guys so much
for this and his book
greater than ever.
Thank you.
[inaudible] we have books in the back.
Okay, good. Great.